you've heard you say an interviews that
about you do walk around kind of on
bother that people don't recognize you
that much which seems incredible yeah no
I I you know living in New York you know
I'm in La now but for years in New York
I just put on a baseball hat and walk
around and I'm kind of I'm not you know
like Ben Affleck you know I grew up with
is six three or six four you know he
just kind of sticks out just no matter
what and and I'm you know 5 10. nobody
looks twice at me it's an ordinary
Heights
you know very people and and and and if
people do recognize me oftentimes I'm
with my kids and they're just really
cool about it I mean I had one
experience here actually uh I was in
Greens Park we were making The Bourne
Ultimatum so this would have been two
thousand
six uh yeah and my daughter was um
was young she she was she was just a
toddler and we and we had her out in in
the park
and it was just uh Lucy my wife and my
daughter and and me and uh
it was kind of a rainy day as you have
here sometimes we're lucky yeah
and uh and it was just us in the park
and we were playing
um with our baby and this young Spanish
couple came kind of strolling down hand
in hand and they kind of looked over and
saw me and kind of went kind of had an
exchange and then pulled out a camera
and came over and
I kind of say to my well here we go you
know I kind of come over and uh the guy
says to me uh please a picture picture
and I said no problem and I went over to
his wife and I put my arm around
looked at me kind of in the
international way that a man looks at
another man
[Laughter]
that he wanted me to take a picture
they're looking for a photographer they
didn't they didn't have any idea who I
was did you humble well it was great my
wife was there to witness the whole
thing that was the first thing I said I
was like oh
so we still joke about that one you know
you shot yourself well yeah I mean I
mean I mean
Emily I'm coming around to you
it's just like a possible situation
most delicious street food things I ever
ate made me ill and but it was delicious
made me ill how ill very ill the idea on
the loo for weeks oh wow it was it was a
pigeon past year in in Marrakech I mean
it sounds like a recipe for if you don't
mind me saying diarrhea yes in the
interest of balance I shot myself in a
bus in Turkey
Emily
[Applause]
I don't have American Prince story
I've never my pants guys I'm sorry
well Steve Michael's this evening are
called Emily Blunt Mary pooping
very good
first day was that iconic possibly I
mean voted maybe one of the greatest
performances of all time yeah and they
we shot that on day one wow yeah I think
it was kind of a baptism by fire but it
was it was a sink or swim moment where I
thought okay this is just a test so if I
can't do this I'm out of here
but the transformation is extraordinary
in here and a bit like keeping the
accent up all the time you did you keep
the teeth in all the time yeah I had his
teeth in because he has a over by a
massive over by which he never wanted to
mess with because he has four octave
range that he said I'm not screwing with
this at all yeah so I had these teeth
made I'm I was like you I enjoyed it so
much I'm not a method actor I'm a method
actor so let's stop okay
no problem with it I'm just saying I'm
not
okay I've ordered I've worked with
method actors that I absolutely adore
and we can go on about that I'll tell
you about this yeah
I kept my teeth in because I never get a
chance to end every sentence with
darling and dear and Freddie does and
that's quite nice it's nice it's nice
being I'd rather be Freddie Mercury for
most of the day than be around me
oh you know what I mean no
um no way you're saying by that and I
appreciate it that's your English but
you had a dialect coach for the English
accent I did yeah because I've lived in
America for so long that that um I live
in California and and I just my kids are
American and
um I just that's the set that's what I
hear around me all day so I have little
things that cut that I don't notice that
sort of slip in so I I had a voice coach
to I had to brush up my English
wow yeah well you'd be Smiley and then
suddenly you'd hit like a hard r or
something or a weird sound would would
come out so uh I needed to sort of have
English lesson because I'm in Cornish
who's in Robocop she was saying
introduce you to a very good Australian
accent
um
now I'm on the spot with someone
well I don't know there's that sort of
that slight there's that sort of subtle
uh kind of accent that's that just sort
of touches the words
[Music]
having not started and then this course
you know like the the full-on you know
possible absolutely
I smell wet concrete uh because uh you
no you this was just a couple of days
ago yeah I think it was like day before
yesterday Hollywood Boulevard right this
is yeah because this is the real honor
isn't it because anybody can get the
star can't they really I've walked down
there I didn't know half those people
around
yes I guess the Hanson feed is reserved
for the uh those who are truly deserving
such as myself but it must be a big you
know for you you grew up there I mean it
must be amazing that there you are that
was kind of a big deal uh it was also uh
raining which was nice first time it
ever rained and then I came here and and
the skies were blue so everything's uh
trippy yes this is this is an
entertaining show isn't it
[Applause]
not at the moment okay
hopes
who met Timothy chalamet before this
hadn't you oh God I had met him about a
year previous we were doing the the kind
of award season rounds together and I
loved his surname chalamet and I every
time I read it I read it as shalomala
bing bong
when I saw him at this event someone was
coming to introduce me and I said in my
head I was like Timothy
as I was walking towards him to the
point where it's now become such a name
in my family that my gran met him last
week at however many weeks ago
and after she came up she's like I met
Timothy
so Timothy Bing Bong but also uh Meryl's
Street yeah I mean your share like you
have scenes with their Wall Street I
shared space with her no we shared a
carriage for a whole day and a room for
a whole day it was and it's better does
she give you a little pep talk
beforehand gonna you're going to be in a
carriage with Meryl Streep you know does
anyone prepare you for it no you kind of
just know that she's she's in the room
or she's somewhere in the house um
because everybody's on best behavior and
everybody lights really quickly and
everybody sets up cameras very quickly
because Meryl's around so you always can
tell that she's somewhere didn't you say
that that when you were doing an outside
scene like she has this power she speaks
and things happen oh she's we were in a
carriage for a long time and it takes a
while to reset shots because we were in
horse we were behind horses and it took
about 20 minutes each time and it was
cold and we were in Boston and Timmy
came up and kind of jumped up on the
carriage and just as he jumped on the
carriage a waft of Chip smell came in
and she suddenly then wanted chips and
within about I'd say 10 minutes there
was a gasping PA like
so I sat in in a carriage dripping in my
fine clothes
um eating Wendy's fries
photographic evidence
[Applause]
everything's delicious
[Music]